une première dans l'histoire canadienne
après dix semaines de préparation tout
était en place pour cette séance virtuel
ou presque
je vois au bonnement d'écrin que nous
sommes présentement 297 est en soi c'est
la preuve que le parlement virtuelle est
un sujet non sans quelques petits pépins
techniques qui rappelle les
vidéoconférences de famille sur dix
n'est à allumer enlever la chose de
parfait j'ai changé la traduction mais
j'oubliais depuis 2000 15 députés qui
apparaissent sans le vouloir et le
téléphone qui sonne chez
[Musique]
l'interprétation simultanée était aussi
un défi auquel madame normandeau
vous êtes canal france et où le canal
anglais où j'ai mis la lame traduction
aof
et parfois la connexion ethernet n'était
pas adéquate même pour les députés qui
était à ottawa même si je suis dans un
bureau du parlement canadien dans un
édifice parlement canadien
j'ai perdu le signal internet malgré les
ratés techniques
la séance s'est plutôt bien déroulé
c'est un premier pas dans le virtuel
pour nous les parlementaires on peut
découvrir la cuisine le bureau des élus
dans son bureau de circonscription à
joliette le bloquiste gabriel
sainte-marie crois que les députés
devront s'adapter travailler de façon
virtuelle
c'est certain que rien comme elle tout
le monde présent ensemble sauf qu'en
même temps c'est certain que la priorité
là c'est lassant type les mesures
sanitaires c'est le meilleur compromis
qu'on pouvait avoir les députés vont
revenir à la chambre des communes demain
pour siéger physiquement mais en groupe
réduit les séances virtuel devrait se
poursuivre au moins jusqu'au 25 mai mais
en coulisses les négociations continuent
alors que les conservateurs réclament
davantage de séance en personne
il suffirait vincent choisi radio canada